today the Yale faith and globalization
seminar is very happy to welcome
ambassador Tony Hall he's been an
American policies and American
politician who has served as a Democrat
from Ohio in the House of
Representatives for more than 20 years
he also served as ambassador to the Food
and Agricultural organization of the
united nations and his chief of the US
mission to the UN agencies in Rome which
includes the World Food Program and the
International Fund for agricultural
development he has also recently
published a book with Tom Price entitled
changing the face of hunger one man's
story of how liberals conservatives
Democrats Republicans and people of
faith are joining forces to help the
hungry the poor and the oppressed he has
served on the board of advisories of
opportunity international a charity that
seeks to end poverty through micro
credit lending of entrepreneurs and as
well he has worked with the Center for
the Study of the presidency which worked
with religious leaders of the Holy Land
principally Muslims Christians and Jews
in the Middle East he's also been
nominated for the Nobel Peace Prize
several times and joins us today in this
seminar to continue to discuss issues of
world hunger Thank You ambassador it's
great to be with you thank you I want to
start by asking you some questions just
about identity as a pro-life Christian
Democrat as well as an ambassador under
a conservative Republican president he
tell us a little bit about how you have
managed these multiple identities in
your political work well I've tried to
do it with sensitivity but it's it's
difficult sometimes because I I wasn't
always a person of faith and when I when
I came to the Congress of the United
States I was not a believer I didn't
have much faith I didn't know a lot
about God even some of my friends or
most of my friends did I mean they were
as far away from it as I was so I didn't
have a foundation on it but anyway I I
became a believer as a result of going
to the Congress United States I know
that sounds funny but
matter of fact it's an interesting story
shortly thereafter a guy introduced me
to this audience and he said now I want
to introduce Tony how is a US
congressman and a Christian and there
was some laughing in the back among the
people and an older man down front he
could take it much longer he said he
hollered up he said hey buddy make up
your mind you can't be both so anyway
I'll get back to your question I became
a believer and shortly they were after
as I began to read the scriptures like I
you know one night I began to see that I
was wrong about the issue of abortion
and wasn't from anybody telling me that
it was just from reading the scriptures
and and feeling that I was wrong and I
changed that the next day it was and the
reason I tell you this because it was
difficult because it was reported in the
in the newspaper as I began to vote as a
pro-life Democrat and people wanted to
know what happened and it wasn't an easy
thing to explain and and it was
difficult from the standpoint that you
know at one time in the democratic party
you mentioned my name and people would
spit you know and a lot of contributions
stopped coming my way as a result of
that but anyway it turned out to be a
good thing because it it was I was able
to establish some independence and some
freedom by by having not only having
that position but that with this
foundation of faith and and being a in a
in political life I was able to have so
much more freedom and it was it was much
easier for me was it difficult yes was I
was I criticized yes was I did people
look at me kind of how can you be a
Democrat and
and you know be a Christian so I was
getting it from both sides I was getting
from the Democrats and the Republicans
so what were the commitments that kept
you Democrat you know I had a lot of
Republicans who come to me good friends
and say why don't you become a
Republican I mean I said why would I
become a Republican be like you know
what I would say to him I said look
there's a lot of people of faith in
though in the Republican Party but at
least as far as in the leadership of the
Democratic Party why would I change I
mean I think we need you know people of
all faiths and different parties I mean
I don't think God was a Republican or a
Democrat I think that he was pretty much
non partisan he looked at the heart of a
person so I felt that I should stay in a
democratic party and there's a lot of
things in the party that I believe in
and and try to maybe within the party
fight these things that I didn't like or
didn't believe in and so that's what I
did I remained in the Democratic Party
and so now how do you feel that the
Democratic Party is addressing issues of
faith are there things that you really
applaud the party for are things that
you're concerned about kind of going
forward yeah the things I like about the
Democratic Party is they they are the
party of the people they they really
care about the working person they
really fight for them they care about
the poor and the sick and as you look at
as you look at the scriptures in both
the Old Testament New Testament is over
2,500 verses that deal with this issue
whether it's the poor the sick the
hungry the elderly people in prison and
it's the second most talked-about theme
in the Bible so I feel the Democrats in
many ways relate very much too many of
the people that Jesus talked about and
so for that reason I stay a Democrat
and work in that in that realm and at
the same time I'm still against many of
the things that certainly the leadership
of the Democratic Party is for you tell
us a little bit about when you think
about elected officials voting on their
conscience even if they if their
constituency has voted for them on a
different issue so say your constituency
has elected you to be pro-life but as a
matter of conscience you don't feel like
or to be pro-choice rather and you don't
feel like you can vote that we can you
tell us a little bit how you think
through that like what your role is as
an elected official on those issues of
faith well I pray a lot on it and I do
remember a situation it wasn't a
pro-life vote but it was a vote several
years ago that had a lot to do with an
issue that was considered anti Democrat
and as a result what happened was is
that I knew that if I voted this way it
would be very difficult for me and my
district would never understand this and
certainly the Democratic Party but it
was something that I felt very clear
about and was one of the and I was a
young believer in ice and I you know I I
really prayed about this and and said
God you you know what you're doing on
this because I think I'm leaning towards
voting this opposite way and this is
going to get me in a lot of trouble and
so it was one of the first times I
really trusted him and stepped out in it
well I voted against my party and it was
perceived as being against my party I
didn't I thought it was a very
principled vote and it had to do with
finances and financial matters and it
was a very very important bill back in
the late 80s anyway the next day the
newspaper said that Hall voted this way
and you know they editorial was the one
after me people went after me letters to
the editors and this guy's a bum bah bah
bah you know
and it was tough it was hard i went back
had a town hall meeting and i've never
seen this or ever heard this before but
I walked into the Town Hall me there's
250 people there soon as I walked in
they all stood up and booed me now I'm
thinking I'm in trouble my staff is
really nervous I'm a little bit nervous
this is the end of my career it's an
interesting thing though the next
campaign nobody ran against me I ran
unopposed so what's that tell you it
tells you that you know do the right
thing even though you're in politics and
people are going to disagree with you I
think what people have always given me
credit for and I appreciate this is that
we might not like the way Tony Hall
votes on certain issues but we respected
that he comes out in very honest way and
he's sincere about it and you know we
like some other that we like a lot of
things that he does but I so I think
sincerity and even though people
disagree with you is the best thing you
can do because the voters in America are
not stupid politicians take them for
granted they kind of think that they're
stupid but they're not and they seem to
make the right decisions and and they do
it often I want to turn a little bit to
the work that you've been doing on
hunger and your book you describe mother
Teresa as a powerful influence in your
work and in your spiritual life
specifically her idea of do what is
right in front of you and I wonder if
you could talk a little bit about how
seeing what's right in front of you and
working how you've been able to maintain
your faith and the in the face of these
tragedies and whether you share with
Mother Teresa some of her doubt you know
I met mother Teresa number of times
first time I met her was in Calcutta and
she took me into one of the poorest
areas of Calcutta and just masses of
people
you know in some cases many of them
laying on the sidewalk very sick or that
was their home they didn't have a place
to go anyway being young in those days I
i said to Mother Teresa I you know
because I was so interested in this
issue i said look at these people i mean
the poverty here I said where does one
start and so she went and picked that
person up and in front of us who was
lying on the sidewalk very sick she got
some people to take him back to her like
hospice and she began to wash him off
and love him and touch him and you know
just do the kind of thing she does with
love that is so amazing and she came
back to me later in the afternoon and
she said we can't all go to Calcutta you
you do the thing that's in front of you
it was a big lesson for me because I've
said the story to several audiences
before when people were saying you know
when we look on television and we see
this and we figure it's too much beyond
us we can't help these people but I'm
frustrated and I'm reminded when Mother
Teresa says do the thing that's in front
of you you know what's going on here in
New Haven you know I mean you don't have
to go to calculators a lot of things
wrong here if every person did the thing
that's in front of them the smile that
you need for some way that's hurting
your next-door neighbor to work in a
food bank or soup kitchen to help the
person that's sick to work with the
elder whatever do the things in front of
you we probably wouldn't need three
fourths the government a that we have
but that's not the way it is her point
was do the things in front of you that's
what Jesus did and she modeled that and
she always said and of course she says
it's often in her books that Jesus is
with the poor and I'd like to be with
the poor because I feel Jesus it's
interesting that you say in your book
that and you're sort of alluding to this
here is that you're not interested in
solving the problem of poverty which is
sort of surprising but rather you say
that you're
mission is for caring for the material
and spiritual needs of others and you
note in your book as well that Jesus did
not seek to solve the problem of poverty
so how do you have a kind of political
theology that isn't about problem
solving like politically we always think
that well you know that's what we're
supposed to do is supposed to fix it
well that's that's the way that's what
we're taught in in Washington when you
come to Washington if you have a problem
you get some congressmen together some
staff you appropriate some money pass a
loss and we'll take care of this problem
we do it all the time yeah nine times
out of ten nothing happens with the law
it's a lousy law it's a waste of money
and you know be an interesting thing if
we were before we would pass a law if we
privately not publicly privately get
together and pray and ask out what do
you think you know this is the way we're
going Lee we don't know whether it's
right or not we don't ask his opinion
and that's not to say that not this is
not done in Washington's a matter of
fact there's a lot of small groups of
Republicans and Democrats that meet
together my best friend and the Congress
is Congressman Frank will have
conservative Republican we we've been
praying together for 25 years so I find
that you know when you get to know each
other and you build relationships and
you pray together it's pretty hard to go
out right after you pray together and
start yelling and debating and being
partisan and I find that we don't solve
all the problems of the world I mean but
we can't work on problems together and
Frank and I work on problems like human
rights we work on hunger we work on a
lot of things that are that are relevant
to people and we solve some of them now
we don't solve all the problems of
poverty in the world but two things that
come before us the things that we can do
we do
you've said that you think that
humanitarian aid is the best defense or
against terrorism right now can you talk
a little bit about that while you think
that well I think that I I remember
meeting this man in Pakistan who told me
that he sent his son to these schools
these schools that teach hate about us
and about Western nations in and there's
a lot of these schools especially in the
Middle East and in pakistan india etc
and i asked him why do you do this why
would you he said frankly i don't like
what they teach him but I don't have any
money I can't feed him I don't have a
job and they pay for everything and he
gets this free education so this is what
we compete against if we're going to
compete against this then why don't we
open up our own schools and and teach
things that are right which we are doing
which are things like for example when
we do a school feeding project one of
the smartest things that we can do is
have school feeding because a lot of
kids stay home because their father or
their mother need them to work in the
fields etc their families won't send
them to school because number one they
can't afford it and number two a lot of
schools don't feed them but when we have
school feeding they go to school they
get fed they get enough enough
nourishment to last him throughout the
day and they not only learn but they're
able to teach them the things that that
that is not hate I've seen this time and
time and time again I've I'll never
forget and I've been in over a hundred
and thirty nations I see lots of
projects and and what I go in people
normally stop me they don't know who i
am but they think i'm some kind of
official so I don't tell them Who I am
unless they ask and and they said you're
from America
we want to thank you for this we really
appreciate this this really helps us
this helps us with our work and this
really makes a difference we don't do
enough of this you want to take the
steam out of people and their hate help
them to eat and help them to get a job
and I'll tell you it takes the steam
it's not the answer it's one of the
answers can you tell us a little bit
about the work you're doing now with the
foundation for hunger and kind of when
you think about the problem of hunger in
the world right now do you think it's a
problem of distribution or of yield like
we need more genetically modified foods
to increase you as like how as the work
that you're doing kind of even think
about why we have the problem of hunger
that we do you know it's a lot of issues
I mean there there's there's reason why
we we have the problem today we have you
know all last year we had high energy
costs so to move the food you know many
miles across the ocean is very expensive
the cost of food itself was was terribly
high we had a lot of droughts in various
countries that produce food and then on
top of that we had civil war corruption
all of those things we produce enough
food in the world when I say we the
countries of the world produce enough
food to feed people and so it is a
problem of distribution it's a problem
of not have it's the problem that we
don't have the food the problem is is
why do we have so much food here and not
so much food there and has a lot to do
with the lack of political will has a
lot to do with the lack of spiritual
will you know this issue belongs to
people of faith believers whether
they're Christian or Muslim or Jews I
mean in all of our scriptures there's
nothing talked about more than this and
as I said before it's the second most
talked-about issue it in our Bible so
this issue belongs
yeah among people of faith and we don't
have enough people involved in this the
church needs to be more involved in this
secondly the political will if we could
get the president united states and he's
saying all the right things right now
President Obama he's saying all Hillary
Clinton there they're very matter of
fact I just read a report that they put
out on hunger global global food
security and it's an amazing piece of
work and if they follow through with
this I think it'll really really make a
difference what we've seen in the past
is we go to these conferences and we say
and we've been doing this since the
1970s we say we're going to end hunger
by the year 2015 you know it's always
before it used to be 1995 and then it
was 19 there was two thousand and two
thousand five now it's 2015 now i see
they just upped it to 2025 they said
we're going to cut in half the number of
people that are hungry by the year 2025
you know we go there with all of our top
people our secretaries of state our
foreign ministers etc etc we sign these
agreements we don't we forget about it
the political will is not there and
people give a lot of rhetoric to poor
people but you don't see a heck of a lot
of leader is really doing much about it
thinking that's going to change I'm
hoping it's going to be changing and
that's that's what I do I work on trying
to build that political will through an
organization that's called the alliance
to end hunger and it's made up of all
the religions or the main religions of
the Jews Christians and Muslims it's
made up of many of the top corporations
in America and and certainly the top
NGOs nonprofits the world vision's the
Catholic Relief Services the oxfam's the
Save the Children I mean and we I
believe and they believe that this issue
can only be solved by bringing everybody
in
the room including government and
working it together so when you think
about or would make a recommendation to
the American people about doing what's
right in front of them what would that
recommendation be in terms of hunger
would it be that we should eat lower on
the food chain so we consume less of the
world's natural resources you know I was
reading that to feed an average American
uses 500 gallons of oil a year so we
consume a very large portion of the
world's resources I mean what would be
the recommendation for some of the ways
that Americans could be attentive to the
problem of world huh that's one way I
mean you know there's a green revolution
is going on now is very important and we
can all do our bet on that we could
volunteer in a food bank we could give
resources to a program in our city we
could work with homeless we could start
a gleaning program we could do a senior
citizen feeding program on during the
cold winter months during during the
winter we could visit people that are
hurting in sick and these these houses
of where they elderly are you know so
many of them are lonely we can do the
thing that's in front of us we can write
our congressmen and demand of our
congressmen not in a hateful way but in
a polite way and go in the same and said
see him or her and say look I care about
this issue I want you to care about this
issue and these are the bills I want you
to vote for and support American people
don't do that enough and let me tell you
as a elected official was 24 years in
the Congress when my constituents would
come to me and say this is important to
us we're watching your vote we need you
I always remembered that always remember
that
while you were remember the house two
times I think it was you made the
recommendation that the US should
apologize for slavery now that both the
House and the Senate have passed
resolutions apologizing for slavery was
not front-page news as you might recall
last year I wonder if you could just
talk a little bit about your perceptions
of how effective those resolutions were
and whether you think now with the
election of President Barack Obama we're
in a post-racial us well I don't know
about post-racial us but I do know that
you know when i introduced the apology
for slavery a few years ago I that was
one of the most difficult issues I ever
introduced because people were outraged
I mean I got more hate mail from around
the country and I mean it was some of
the most hideous things in the world
were said about me it was so I it opened
my eyes at at this problem that still is
brewing sometimes on the service but
well below the surface as well to how we
hate and the thinking of some of the
people in our country I was surprised i
also got some of the most beautiful
letters and some of the most warmest
thoughts and beautiful prayers that I
ever had we passed that I had I left
Congress and Congress eventually passed
that and it remains to be seen what is
going to happen with that I mean we did
apologize but nothing formally has
happened and I think the United States
is gradually changing relative not only
to that issue but to some other issues
but we have a long way to go and it's
something that we have to constantly be
aware of be on top of and
we need a lot of work and so in terms of
when you think about President Obama
getting the nobel peace prize in part
because he's been able to inspire hope
and people's moral imagination what do
you make of that is that part of what
you think of as what will move us to
racial equality in the United States I
think probably that might have been one
of the reasons why he was given a Nobel
Peace Prize I would I I was rather
surprised that he got it and I felt that
you know I feel the prize you go to
somebody that's not just because he
looks like he's going to do something
but he's done something and so you know
we needed to wait you know I voted for
President Obama I like him I think he's
an amazing person in so many ways I'm
excited that he is the president you
knighted States but let's give him a
chance let's let's give him some years
and let's see what he does and he has
instincts and the direction he's going
in I think are very good so I would have
held off on that Nobel Prize for him I I
think it's premature you want to talk a
little bit about the hunger strike or
fasting that you did as part of your
work against hunger yeah i did a fast
for 22 days and i didn't eat anything i
just drank water and i did it in protest
of the Congress United States not only
eliminating the Select Committee on a
hunger of which I was the chairman of
but the hypocrisy of Congress sometimes
when we really need to adjust serious
issues they kind of look the other way
and so I was so taken back by it and so
hurt and the frustration of the the lack
of conscience towards the issue of
people of that were poor that in talking
to my wife and in reading this wonderful
passage from Isaiah Isaiah 58
about what a true fast is about I
decided to do a hunger fast and my staff
was very worried about this because you
know that's going to end your career
Tony how many people are never going to
understand this there's never been a
congress on that ever fasted I mean how
are you going to handle this and it was
really down on faith it was really I
read Isaiah 58 my wife was with me and
friends were with me that that I
believed in and I thought you know this
is probably the end of my career because
nobody will ever understand this it's
too out there it's to a little bit it's
on the edge and so I went before the
capital and there was that I had a big
press conference a lot of microphones
and I said well this place doesn't have
a conscience and I'm sick of this that
it's not going on and here's what I'm
going to do I'm going to go on a fact
not going to eat now I'm not going to
hurt myself and I'm going to kill myself
I'm not making that kind of a
demonstration but don't I'm not going to
eat until something good happens about
this issue that's it I ended it boom and
I went back to my district in Ohio and I
asked them you know I thought well I
might as well face in music my district
will never understand this I mean this
is an issue of why would anybody fast
for something like this especially
elected official I mean so I went back
there and and I just so happened to have
a speech in front of a very large high
school and I told him what I was doing
starting that day and they were they all
decided to fast with me including the
students teachers and their parents now
they didn't faster 22 days they took a
day or two but as I went through the
fast the newspapers and the reporters
began to really write about this in an
interesting why a wonderful way saying
this
kind of lonely congressman was was doing
this fast and it was for the reasons of
poverty and hunger and and they began
both on the left on the right they began
to write amazing editorials and do
stories and this thing caught on 200
universities fasted with me now not
everybody in university but maybe 50
kids here and 50 kids there and then and
I was told to 10,000 high schools or
involved with it and then a lot of other
good things happened they began to have
lots of seminars lots of programs
started but the thing that got me to
finish the fast because I was waiting
for mean all these things were good but
I was waiting for something bigger and
the world bank called me and said were
moved by this fast and we want to do
something and we're thinking about
having a large meeting based on your
fast and they saw they invited these
world leaders the Secretary General at
the time of the UN was a fella by name
of boutros boutros-ghali and other world
leaders ambassadors came and you know a
lot of speeches I made us I made a
speech was based on the fast why and
when it was over they they they
committed shortly thereafter that one
hundred million dollars to the fast that
was for the most part given out over a
series of years mostly to women and very
poor nations very developing nations for
microfinance microcredit to produce
their own jobs
and that was the thing that really got
me to stop my fast the important thing
about the fast was that I just stopped
eating I didn't have a plan our campaign
people prayed but God did he did the
whole thing and it was one of the most
interesting exciting things I've ever
done I've never felt so close to God in
all my life my wife said to me you know
during those 22 days you had a glow
about you she said now I haven't seen
that glow since then but during that
time it was pretty good it was
interesting okay so that was the fast um
it's interesting just think about the
changes in the way we have politically
organized like when I was growing up my
mom would often boycott things like oh
we're not eating coffee or we're not
buying grapes or whatever and there's we
don't seem to do that as kind of
community organizing anymore and you're
fasting reminds me of how different say
the generation of our students in terms
of when they want to make political
protest and when they organize there are
different mechanisms now much more
technologically generated you know kind
of emails and you know crowds gathering
in protest maybe sometimes on the steps
of some government office wonder if you
could think a little bit about would you
recommend fasting again would you
recommend some of these older absolutely
I fasting is kind of a lost art I mean a
lot of people don't do it it's very
biblical and fasting only works if you
do it unto God now if you if you're
fasting because you want to lose weight
in my work Beyonce Lord image whatever
diet yeah there's a lot of reasons that
you can fast but when you fast unto God
I mean Isaiah 58 really comes alive
comes alive so do you think you can be
called to political life well I don't
know I said that's a tough issue I i was
in political life when I became a
believer so I went into political life
not knowing anything about God or faith
nor did I really care about it but then
in political life is when I became a
believer so was i called the political
life and I wouldn't necessarily say that
although I think God has his hand on all
of us and he knows our hearts and God
set it up that way that he works through
us he uses us I mean he really doesn't
need us I mean he can make things happen
if he can make the stones talk but he
chose to work through us so if
somebody's called something I couldn't
very why I can't say that I don't know
but when you say that you think that God
has his hand on everything I know that
you've suffered both politically it
sounds like and personally how do you
make sense of you know the suffering
that you see in Calcutta and the
suffering that you've had in your own
life I don't make sense out of it I had
lived by faith my son died of leukemia
you know and it was very difficult for
my wife and I and we struggled just
killed us and I didn't know if I was
ever going to make and I thought about
jumping off of a building every day
almost and I was barely hung on but when
I came through that experience I had
more faith in God then when I went into
it no I can't explain that
I don't know it's grace it's it's love
it's God that stayed close those are
there are things you can't explain and
that's one of them Thank You ambassador
for spending this time with thank you